in 2013 you got asylum in France and you
live in France now and that must have
been an interesting time to move to
France because shortly after that was
the Charlie Hebdo attacks now you you
knew some of the cartoonists right you
had work with them a little bit so can
you talk about that well I knew all the
cartoonist and those who died and those
who survived as well we had well we were
friends we were really friends and we
spent a lot of time just together
debating discussing and sharing what we
shared a lot of ideas and to be honest
when I arrived to France and after few
of protests that we organized in France
and clearly stated our direct message
not message which is following all the
demands of political correctness you
know unnecessary political correct yes
in Europe Charlotte dog were the only
one who were really on the same line
with us and we became really your friend
and it's very very soon and we even made
a one issue of Charlotte though together
with FEMEN um and well yeah and of
course we will sometime we were spending
ridging to each other the threats that
we were receiving and laughing you know
and King fan of the of the fanatics who
were spending time for writing those
threats and you know writing these
speeches which they were reading
recording on our voicemails yeah and of
course losing your friends not only
friends you know yeah not only friends
but I geologic ideological friends or
brothers if you want was of course was
again something which of course is
personally very hard and heavy rules but
also is something that revealed the load
and shows you again shows you that if
you stop then you will fail and your
ideas will faith I believe that maybe it
would be it will sound a bit all but but
even those cartoonists who died who were
killed
they didn't lose and their ideas you
know they're not the ideas are not
failure they they will always remain as
yes and those who continue to do what
they believed in and that what they
believe in is the right thing because
they were not harming anyone they were
contributing to a very important thing
such as freedom of expression and they
were contributing to this to keep and
save the values of France as well which
is a Liberty goleta fraternity which is
you know sometimes today you think that
it it remains only on the building's
written on the buildings but not
actually in life not actually applied in
life of society anymore so Charlie blow
our heroes a part of being friends they
are heroes however I should also mention
that just the months before what they
they were killed they were racist
Islamophobes you know they they were
always named for being too much for
going too far for offending we all know
that right and just to be very clear I
know this has been said a thousand times
over but they were not racist and they
were not Islamophobes which is a made-up
word by the way but they were not they
were pointing out the they made fun of
everybody and I think something like
it's three percent of the covers were
about Islam but they equally attacked
Christianity and Judaism and all the
religions it was about power so they
were making cartoons about the exact
things that you were protesting in the
streets it was really kind of amazing
but what happened should was Charlie 00
and the fact what you mentioned just
right now they'd only three percent of
the covers and the the old material in
newspaper was about Islam also show
something that we were also discussing
with them often and you know as we
talked about France and things that
happen in France maybe it will make
sense to quote volterra game here and
this words attributed to him he said
that if you want to find out who rules
over you simply understand who you are
not allowed to criticize so even this
three percent you know of the
the information or the the the topic you
know isla um that was just taking three
percent of the of the whole information
of Charlotte though really shows a lot
so that of course is the youngest from
three monotheistic religions the most
ambitious probably today the most
demanding religion really reveals its
face to face and reacts in a different
way so I know you've talked about the
regressive left and it start for me
Charlie Hebdo was the beginning of my
awakening and which happened over the
course of the next year or so but what
do you make of the group of people and
we had plenty of them here in the United
States and I'm sure you had plenty of
them in France as well people on the
Left people that are for women's rights
and for gay rights and for minority
rights that's suddenly when it came to
what happened with Charlie Hebdo zata
you shouldn't have you know you
shouldn't have made fun of the the
cartoons you shouldn't have done these
cartoons talked about the Prophet
whatever it is people who otherwise are
totally for free speech and free
expression suddenly they're not in this
case so what do you make of those people
and how pervasive is that idea in France
these days well you said that it's all
started for you after Charlotte though I
think that it became so visible in
France as well after Charlotte dough and
recently also after cologne attacks in
Germany which we can also discuss not
only leftist but also feminist reaction
or feminist non-reaction so I think that
yeah it's after this events we could see
this you know fraction of leftist who
would deny dins the essential problem
who would be scared to talk about the
roots of the problem who will who will
be willing not to to talk about
Charlotte dah killers as people with
guns and not discuss their ideas and not
discuss what they were screaming while
shooting our friends what they were in
in the name of who they committed these
atrocities and what made them could
believe and
that they have to do that so I think
that this is something again which of
course brings Europe in a very big
danger and especially the values of
Europe in a very big danger and
therefore I say that sometimes walking
in Paris I read these three words that
the slogan of French Revolution and I
understand that this is very far from
reality today from the society and of
course you hear the leaders the leftist
leaders here who try to you know make a
speeches to defend freedom of expression
and make of Charlotte though heroes
because they're you know journalists who
fell down but they do not will they do
not want to discuss for which ideas they
they failed it for which ideas they were
killed so many of them you know of
course do it out of fear but very
different fear there is a very big fear
to be to have similar speech to
right-wing similar speech to actual
extent of bulbs and and racist right ah
such as from nacional with marine lepen
here in France therefore left is decided
to take this very ridiculous again
intellectually dishonest position such
as denying their roots then they you
know the real the essential problem in
this situation and I think this way to
betray also the ideas of shadow of the
sport um and of course yeah so and at
the end of the result is that it's only
or extreme right-wing the racist
eccentric xenophobes who are speaking
out actually yeah and this is this is
what I've said repeatedly here is that
we on the Left have to deal with this
because if we don't and this is exactly
what your piece in the International
Business Times was about if if the if we
don't deal with the regressive left then
who do we hand it to the racist right
that way that was your your term and I
couldn't agree more so when you say that
France in terms of free speech and
people getting along would you
say France is in a worse position now do
you think that there was a net loss in
free speech after Charlie Hebdo because
there were a couple weeks after where
the whole world united and and I'll you
know all those world leaders came to
Paris and it sounded like something good
was going to happen but I sense you
think it's probably the reverse now well
again there are so many aspects to
discuss here this manifestation that
happened after 11th of January was
ridiculous and the the cartoonists who
survived loose for example who made the
next cover with Mohammed with profit
crying we were laughing with him it's a
parody it's true word we were laughing
because in front of him there was a line
of all the enemies of ideas of Charlotte
though and they were marching you know
again this event was so full of
hypocrisy yeah because fact they were
marching at least this front line were
marching not for the not for the right
ideas you know they were pretending they
were yeah it was it was fake I'm not
talking about the million of people who
write out but I'm talking about this
front line which was totally ridiculous
and what happened after there was so
many events dedicated to discussion of
free speech which were close we were
which were cancelled by the government
by police in order to you know for
security reasons events in which me
myself was supposed to participate so
many of them were cancelled again the
event that happened just one month after
in Copenhagen during which i was
speaking was interrupted by another
terrorist and again one person have been
killed mayor some injured so this way
you know again I think that we failed
after Charlotte though we failed with
all these ridiculous things such as
inviting actually the representatives or
those of those who are feeding the
terrorists those who feed this
ideas that are well actually cannot
coexist with ideas of freedom of speech
inviting them to Paris to march for
ideas of Charlotte though is something
that already showed that we will fail in
this discussion and I don't want to make
a conclusion that we did fail but I feel
we are failing here in Europe the Europe
is failing European society is failing
because they're not ready to well to
face very uncomfortable very unpleasant
but truth they are not they are not able
to hear unpopular speech and I if
freedom of speech is really about
something if liberties really something
it's definitely about unpopular speech
it's about hearing accepting this
unpopular and comfortable speech yeah
and group is failing of doing that so we
only have a couple of minutes left I
know we're just getting into the meat of
this so we're gonna have to do this
again where we can talk for much longer
but I hear you on the Europe art and
that's I get so much email now from the
same piece of people saying the same
things in Denmark and in France and in
Germany and Finland all of these
countries people are saying the exact
same things that you're talking about
and they feel that there's no faith in
the government that the governments are
going to do the right things and all of
that so so let's end on this so the
cologne event that that happened in
Germany with this it sounds like a
thousand men were running rampant
throughout the city and it's unclear if
they were all immigrants or migrants or
whatever it was the reaction to that
must have been particularly upsetting to
you because it dealt with sort of the
the free speech stuff and bringing all
these people in but it also directly
this was a direct assault on women so it
really went to or everything that you
care about was the reaction to that
because i saw feminists that were not
defending the women I suddenly saw a
feminist online well-known feminists
that were saying oh this is just an
excuse for the xenophobes and white men
do it too and all of those things so
that wasn't one must have been
particularly upsetting right well it was
yeah of course it was not only on not
only upsetting um you know I think that
yeah today we use you look around
see that those who was supposed to be
your allies those who's supposed to
share with you with a very fundamental
values and stand for them either keep
silence or try to support actually you
aggressors the graces of women just
because of the fact it was reported that
among the aggressors were man who looked
like Arabic men or North African origin
feminist silence they didn't want to
discuss what really happened just
because of fear of again being you know
having the speech of extreme right wing
and at the end who appeared to be actual
defenders of women you know who were
raped and aggressed after colon were
extreme right-wing again the platform
was giving to them so i think that to
those people who write you emails and
two people who write me as well a lot
and for support who feel very who feel
betrayed sad by the situation with that
is going on today in europe by leftist
reactions by the reaction some of
reaction of the feminist i think that we
have to understand that to be sad is not
enough to be sad you know makes people
cry and stay at home and Phil you know
alone but what we have to be many people
don't like to face it but what we have
to be today we have to be angry I think
the anger brings people to action not um
hate but anger anger for defend you know
for the fact that your ideas are
attacked that something very essential
for your life and joy of life which
people have today here opportunity to
enjoy life today here in Europe you have
to defend it and for that you have to
feel anger don't feel sad Phil angering
act and defend your ideas and don't let
extreme right-wing write your own
history let's write it with our own
beautiful liberal ideas that's my
message well you know I don't even have
to ask you a final question because you
couldn't have and
this any better you absolutely have an
ally in me and I'm sure much of my
audience so everyone can find more of
inas work at inna desh shevchenko calm I
thank you for joining me and we
absolutely will do this again because I
feel like we just we just touched the
surface of all this so thank you thank
you I appreciate it
you